luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we've got jake
and luke from how to alaska and they are
going to be joining us on an epic
alaskan adventure
we're gonna be hunting fossils whoa we
might do some gold mining
we're gonna be camping you guys ready
well check it out we rented this utv
from alaska toy rental and palmer
but i've never used one of these utvs
before so i'm really excited to give
this a try
i'll be the one that's pushing harder
are you ready
oh this is awesome we can't even do this
i feel like i'm in a tank
oh look at that look at that a bobcat
you see that a bobcat just ran across
the road
trying to make the noise like a wounded
rabbit see if they can get him to pop
his head up
scoot over buddy here comes something
meatier
guys you want some blueberries yeah oh
man look at these
[Music]
oh check it out guys got some
crowberries here
it's really fun riding that thing it is
comfortable
and at my age i'm starting to appreciate
comfort a bit more
[Music]
i'm so glad you guys
oh look at that guys you know what that
is look at
look at that this is all bear crap
[Applause]
[Music]
we got the heater there let's turn that
up
zombie windshield wiper activate
that's why we wear a rain gear how's
that thing running
it's doing pretty good boys are a little
hungry so jake's pulling out a trail
snack
this is pink salmon this is red salmon
kids get the pink salmon
adults get the red salmon nice
that's good you like that that's good
the big stamp is fine too but it's not
red too
red salmon is way better that's better
we had a nice snack break let's uh let's
go find some fossils
there we
ah here we go
there we go all right guys you're out of
looking for fossils
[Applause]
that's the big old moose print right
there so this is the kind of rock you're
going to find
fossils in right here oh here oh yeah
here we go here we go
see look i mean nothing fancy but you
can see the seashells in it
oh look guys bones
look at these little bones they feel
like bird bones
super exciting but there's a bellum
knight in there oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah this is all the
seashells this fossil ferris shale
oh look at that
oh yeah look at that right there there
look at right here oh yeah that's a big
one
whoa oh that's a huge one that was huge
yeah that looks like a fossilized
whimper that does look like a fossilized
olympics
i found one that isn't broken at all oh
yeah that one's in great shape oh look
behind you
look at all the bellum knights in here
oh
isn't that cool that is cool look at all
that
oh look at that
that that brown oh yeah yeah yeah that's
a fossil that's a
bow oh you know so let's see
yeah look at that that's cool
there we go look at that what did it
come out oh
nice
oh this is one of the most gorgeous
places i've ever hunted for fossils
oh yes isn't this great
put all the fossils
check it out that's the way we came
up through that valley and that's the
way we're going
wow
wow this thing goes through water just
so well
he's kind of
wow that that splashed all the way up in
here didn't it
luckily the engine intake is in the back
and it's covered over a bunch of stuff
so you can go into some pretty deep
water and as long as you don't linger
it's
not too bad
this is so much
we're fun on an airstrip it's used by
the miners and
the homesteaders back here to get
supplies
check it out we have some gold mines up
ahead these guys are working excavators
and slush boxes
the big rocks get sorted out and then
the dirt gets sprayed with water
all the gold and heavy dirt gets
separated and then he takes and pans
the leftovers and gets the gold out i
mean in two hours
really good oh there it is maybe it may
be graham and him
might
oh my goodness those are just gorgeous
oh that's cool
all right guys hop in one time
[Music]
oh wow look how deep that is
all right guys you ready to find some
more fossils yeah yeah
all right yeah look at that you got some
raspberry bushes there
whoa
oh yeah i can see it yeah yeah yeah i
got it
there's some fossils on that one we're
gonna find it is the big rocks roll to
the bottom
yeah but they hang up in the trees i
want you to stay with me
a little bit more oh yeah
oh yeah there's a nice impress we're
that's cool
yes just make a little ledge just put
your feet it's the last day of august
and the leaves are already turning
yellow
fall comes quick around here reach for
me my son
you're almost there you gotta do it oh
you did it
you're safe just take jumps and and then
it's easier to stop yourself
just go and hop like a bunny as tommy's
gonna do it hop like a buddy
tom's down okay
careful don't get going too fast stop
nade stop
[Music]
oh check it out you find one oh yeah
yeah you get a good oh it gives you an
idea what we're looking for it's kind of
a rams horn style
shell and they get big here we go
this is what we're looking for hopefully
i can
get it without busting it
oh a piece of an ammonite or something
yeah buy it
oh too greedy oh
you can see all the guts of it oh
awesome
look at the calcite in there yeah let's
see look at the crystals
look at the krause of crystals
jake found it it's this is no
jake's cool fossil look at that
that is way cool here's another one oh
yeah i can see that's
that's the inside it's just a little
quarter of it look at that
beautiful absolutely beautiful oh you
can see all the chambers
that's a great one and see the crystals
growing inside the shell
[Music]
wow
i got you you did it
i gotta tell you what guys i like these
utvs man
these things are awesome all right hold
on to your butts it's gonna get bumpy
here we go again
all right hold on tight everybody
you want to go explore real quick guys
there's a creepy bus
all right let's go inside and see if
there's a little school kid skeletons
look at the mud slides have hit the side
of the box see the dirt comes all the
way up to the windows
i would love to know the back story of
how this thing ended up all the way back
here oh look it's an army bus it says us
army bus
for official use only all right all
aboard
all right kids school of hard knocks is
now in session
you're the best school bus driver ever
oh no
all right kids come on
i hope some stretchy pails
we're coming up on jake's gold claim
that's a nice setup
yeah look at that
that was awesome oh yeah i can see why
you'd want to
make this a gold clay you got bedrock
right down here gold sits on top of
bedrock
right
yeah now we're talking
i need you to squish this bag up and mix
up all that dough in the bag
all right guys i'm gonna show you one of
my favorite things it's rendered bacon
fat
requires little or no refrigeration and
it is the ultimate
oil grease for dutch ovens frying pans
that sort of thing
warming up right here
okay
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
oh when it's really upset anyone wants
some non spider
there you go kind of a a hearty non it's
nice and warm
better but you know why i know the best
part of
the dirt is very soft so
i think we're okay that is a perfect
marshmallow luke from one luke to
another
well done okay these are very
great it's still good
yeah so but that helps but i need to
drop it or no i hear about it
you know i felt from there if he's gonna
force me so we're sitting there
guys do you know how late it is it's 9
30. it's your bedtime no oh
oh my spanking hand is getting itchy
oh you warm yeah yeah good
what an awesome awesome day we have had
such a ball getting out here
but it is late i'm exhausted and i will
see you guys
in the morning
oh cold
this morning breakfast burritos sound
pretty good to me
i think uh i think we better get
cracking on that
[Music]
would you guys like to shoot the 22 oh
yeah
all right let's set up a little target
range huh
here just put it right here tom see this
stick
this right here is the line okay okay
that's the tip of the bullet now there's
a bullet in there then you squeeze the
trigger
shoot you go okay
you're ready to fire tommy
i like this we're getting ready to do
some gold mining here
on jake's gold claim but one of the
biggest
obstacles to mining gold is getting the
wetsuit on
jake's just a little bit fluffy like me
it's like a chip and dale dancer who's
about to pull a muscle
all right jake's busting out the dredge
the bedrock's really shallow which is
good because the gold hangs up on the
bedrock
that's sucky
that's a lot of work that is a lot of
work but it's
fun and it's rewarding yeah i did that
for like two seconds and my hands are
frozen
see all that gravel in there there's
lots of gold in that
and we're gonna use the pan to get the
gold out did you find some
yup i found it oh look at that look
at that oh yeah look at that there's a
bunch right there
you have a little vial or something
little piece of gold right there
you got to be pretty gentle with it
you know a couple tablespoons of
material in my pan
oh my that's impressive
well there you go about an hour hour and
a half of dredging
and about a hundred dollars worth of
gold so
not too shabby the boys have had an
absolute ball
playing on the shale slide over here
they've almost broke their neck like 10
times but
they're having fun hey nathan what'd you
find over there
a knife look take a look at this
man yeah
that's actually in really good shape
nathan wayne right down you found it
right there
downloading this area look at that
well the boys and i have had an absolute
ball hanging out with jake and luke
and if you guys want to see more great
outdoor adventures that are family
friendly check out their channel i'll
put a link in the description below but
we've got to get headed home and we've
got
a great trail ahead of us i'm really
excited
for the ride back
have you had a good time yeah all right
guys get loaded up in the utv we're
getting out of here
would you guys like to do this again
sometime yeah
it's just up to you up front yeah
the boys have decided that we should
name the utv appa after the flying
buffalo on avatar
this is oppa my flying bicycle
[Music]
serious ride or die remember
we didn't get rained on last night but
apparently up in the valley above us it
did get rain
the rivers are a little bit dirty and a
little bit higher
than when we crossed the first time so
it's a little bit of a clencher getting
back home
you were wearing your rain pants yep
ah kurt pushed us a little bit
[Music]
i'm glad we had the window shut on that
one
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
bye
foreign
all right tommy we're gonna give you a
turn okay yep
welcome aboard i'm going to do some
[Music]
driving
[Music]
he said it's your turn
[Music]
oh
[Music]
guys did you have fun yeah
if you guys enjoyed this video as much
as we enjoyed filming it don't forget to
click subscribe
to the outdoor boys youtube channel and
don't forget to check out our
six week adventure here in alaska
i'll put a link in the description to
that video as well and check out
jake's youtube channel how to alaska for
more
family-friendly outdoor adventures
thanks for watching guys
see you next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button
and you'll get notifications thanks for
watching